the nine films nominated for Best
Picture tonight are exhilarating and
original inspiring and unforgettable
they represent the best of what we do
and prove that incredible stories told
with talent vision and style invigorate
our imaginations broaden our minds
humble our hearts and stir our souls
here are the nominees for Best Picture
American hustle
captain Phillips
Dallas buyers club
gravity
her
Nebraska
Filomena
12 years a slave the wolf of Wall Street
and the Oscar goes to
12 years of slave Jeremy
thank you all thank you for this
incredible honor you stowed on our film
tonight I I know I speak for everyone
standing behind me that has been an
absolute privilege to work on Solomon's
story and we all get to stand up here
tonight because of one man who brought
us all together to tell that story and
that is the indomitable mr. Steve
McQueen oh wow
I'm sure I'm sorry I apologize for the
paper but otherwise I'll just bore you
all
well maybe I'll do the same now but I'll
try not to my first like to thank the
Academy thank you so much
a lot of people need to thank so I'll
just push on through what my wonderful
cast and crew plan B flat Brad Pitt who
without him this filter without him this
film would just not have been made did
he guarded Jeremy kleiner and Antigua
Tagus River Road bill Pollard New
Regency Arnold Miller and bad western
film for to the great Tessa Ross and Fox
Searchlight Steve Lula and hence the
Utley and their fantastic team my
publicist for the words I'm sorry about
this boom for hard work April lamb and
my magnificent agents I have to say this
these all with these women
I mean I've all women in my life and
they're all the most powerful my mother
obviously but the day this is my heart
mark Dickey and even parents at my I
forgive me I'm nervous confidentially
when Marg you know who our best Warford
Jenny Kaz righto enjoy DeShields I just
give me one more minute I'd like to
thank this amazing historian sue akin
whose life she gave her life's work to
preserving Salman's book I like to thank
my parlour banker stick to an earthing
this treasure for me finally I'd like to
thank my mother my mum's up there
thank you for your hard hitting this mum
thank you and my children Alex and
Dexter and my father thank you for the
last word
everyone everyone deserves not just to
survive but to live this is the most
important legacy of its Ormond Northup I
dedicate this award to all the people
who have endured slavery and the 21
million people who still suffer slavery
today thank you very much thank you
you